all right how's everyone doing today
everyone's good good okay my name is Joe
Matthews at Joe Matthews on the tech
Lahoma slack channels you know you can
at Joe Matthews me anytime and I'll come
show up mysteriously and on Twitter Joe
Matthews okay see and I want to talk
today about github pages I love github
pages it's a weird obsession and I think
Kimberly caught on to that it's like do
a talk do it
and so github pages is an awesome
service allows you to host HTML CSS and
JavaScript and a little bit of extra
functionality too for free dollars three
dollars people and that's pretty amazing
and it's pretty rare out on the
interwebs to get that without ads or
anything like that
kind of harkens back the Geo cities days
a little bit but much better and the
fact that it just works and it works
well so I could go on and on about get
up pages I thought about doing like you
know just a good five minutes of just
talking about how much I loved it but
instead I have an official github pages
video and this is at pages github calm
and we'll go through a tutorial from
that site as well here in a little bit
but let me just go and play this video
real quick if you're a software
developer github helps you build all
sorts of great things things that help
people things that could land you a job
things that could change the world and
some things that might not so how do you
tell the world about all the great
things you're building billboards Direct
Mail these days you build a website and
there are lots of options out there but
so many of these options can be
excessive or overwhelming even for
someone who develops software get up
pages lets you turn github repositories
into elegant websites to showcase your
portfolio your projects their
documentation or anything else you want
to share with the world there are no
databases to set up and no servers to
configure in many cases you don't even
have to know HTML
everything just works if you're already
using github it's the most direct path
to create websites for you and your
projects so how does it work well github
serves all of your project sites from a
personal URL tied to your user name or
organization github looks for web
content for your projects on a special
branch for sites tied to an existing
repository this branch is separate from
your code but you can also create a site
for yourself for your organization by
creating a repository with your github
pages URL as its name and adding web
content to its master branch you can
even drag and drop your files straight
into your browser to upload now if you
want to build something a bit more
ambitious like a blog or structure of
documentation get up pages gives you a
streamlined publishing experience with
the help of Jekyll Jekyll is an
open-source tool that transforms plain
text files into websites but it also
supports things like variables templates
and drafts which give you more control
over the format and presentation of your
site now no matter which path you choose
github pages lets you treat your
website's content with the same level of
care as the source code and all of your
projects because your website's files
are part of a github repository you can
maintain them using the same family of
tools and workflows you already use on
github you can use the github flow to
manage changes to your website you can
even write tests and have github report
the status back to you before merging
those changes in when you're ready to
publish changes just merge them in
github automatically builds and deploys
your site for you this frees you up to
focus on the content of your site
instead of worrying about how you'll get
it from your computer to everyone else's
browser try out github pages with one of
your projects today navigate to the
Settings tab of your project and use the
automatic page generator to create your
first site get up will populate your
page with some basic content that you
can customize with markdown if your
project already has a readme file you
can import its content here too
when you're finished editing choose one
of the pre-built beams and publish your
site if you need to make changes to this
page you can always rerun the automatic
page generator or edit the files
directly on github for now if you browse
to your site's URL you can see it's up
and running with a few clicks you can
have something beautiful online but this
is only a fraction of what you can do
visit pages github.com to learn more
about all the possibilities github is
the place where you can build great
things get up pages gives you a way to
share those great things with everyone
[Music]
thank you get up it's a great video
alright so that went through a lot and
github pages can do a lot and its
essence it's a simply a web server you
know you have index dot HTML you have
your CSS and JavaScript and it hosts it
just like Apache or nginx would that's
pretty cool stuff but it also has some
integration with Jekyll as it showed and
that allows you to do a whole lot more
but there's though there's a first step
in all that and that's the create a
github account so bear MIT bear with me
while we go through this and you can do
you can join github I going to get hub
comm /join alright and so for these
examples
it's a little hard to see I know but it
says show me - gh - pages and that's
username I chose for all these examples
and I got the email address and another
password and so we move on to step two
which is to choose your plan let's go
with unlimited public repositories for
free should be open we should share our
software and step three tailor your
experience I just go ahead and skip this
to get skip this step it's kind of like
a social media thing what are you
interested in it's also kind of a survey
type of thing we move on and you're
presented with this lovely screen and so
you know you might be asking ok what now
how do we get started with github pages
alright the command line tutorial so the
same place that had the video earlier
there is a tutorial on pages github com
and this is the command line version
alright and so this is what the the page
starts off with what it looks like it's
very nice site and by the way the
documentation for github pages and
github documentation general is amazing
that's my opinion
but it's amazing just just take my word
for it so the first step you know head
over to github and create a new
repository name username github Dino dot
IO for our examples that's show me - gh
- what was it pages dot github that I oh
and you know so we're username put your
username alright next step go to the
folder where you want to store your
project and clone the new repository so
I just go ahead and hit get clone or
type in git clone and then the address
of your repository remember it ends with
github io all right then go ahead and
change directory to the user named I
could have that io that should be the
folder name after you clone it and then
hit that run the echo program command
and go ahead and send that into an
index.html and so all that index.html
will say is hello world and then we get
at all
get commit and then the the dash in for
message initial commits and then get
push and the dash do to indicate that
you always want to upload to
origin/master
alright and then you're all done
so you go to your file browser and go to
your username github I oh and might you
know in our case it's showing me github
pages so you see at the top show me -
github pages github that I oh and there
you go hello world and that is my
presentation for today thank you thank
you
not really so if you're like this guy
you know you might say what just
happened and so you got get clone CD
echo get add git commit git push so
these you know there's a lot of Linux
tool knowledge here and not everyone's
up to speed on that so raise of hands
like who has some experience with HTML
CSS JavaScript almost everybody awesome
who has experience with the Linux
command line
tools involved with that a lot of people
you know those that don't don't worry
because for the rest of this tutorial we
are not going to focus on Linux tools
and we're going to focus instead on
going through you know going the the
easy button route and adding files to
the repository
violet via github com the web interface
which is pretty cool
alright so to get to get started with
that go ahead and click on new
repository and then you're presented
with oh okay yeah we have to verify the
email address can never skip that so go
ahead click verify email address and
your pot back here go ahead and click on
new repository again and then go ahead
and plug in the same thing it did on the
tutorial for you to type in in this case
show me da - gh - pages github I owe and
then we need to click initialize this
repository with re me this is important
because if you don't do this it won't
give you some of the options going
forward and so this kind of populates
readme dot MD file that basically just
says the name of the repository and
that's it that helps us get on to the
next steps so the next step so after you
you know click great repository you're
presented with this beautiful page and
the button that we want to focus on
right now and as I can see here laser
points working so there's a readme and
here it shows you the readme right here
and that's all that's in our repository
so we're going to create a new file so
you click that create new file button
and then that presents you with some
options and so you got to name the file
we're going to name it index.html kind
of like in the example the command line
and instead of just putting in hello
world we're gonna you know put a little
bit more boilerplate in here you know
make Google happy a little bit and so we
do the doctype HTML we do the HTML
element the body element h1 and then
hello world and then we have a paragraph
that says I'm hosted with github pages
alright and then we go to the bottom and
you could see like if you don't type
anything at all it's going to give you a
message that you can use you know create
index dot HTML is very reasonable so if
you look at your get history 50 million
or get you get ajust a bonus there
and so go ahead and commit the new file
I click on that green button at the
bottom and then you're presented with
hello world again but this time you did
it without having to know any linux
knowledge and for everyone in the room
at this point I think you know you feel
like fin over here and your mind is just
blown you're like what can't I make
right now what can I put on the internet
right now you know and be responsible of
course be responsible and so let's let's
talk about some more practical examples
so let's talk about Nyan Cat nyan nyan
cat all right
I had never pronounce it right all right
and so we're gonna convert code pin it
convert a code pin to github pages and
so everyone on you know if you take go
to free code camp you know some of the
projects on there they have you use code
Bend you know kind of demonstrate your
work and cope in is an excellent tool
and show you a little bit what it looks
like I found this one nyan cat follow
Mouse a code penned by Bruno Cunha and
this is a pretty cool code pin and so
your you know your you know I don't the
bottom will just would normally show you
you know the result of these you know of
this code but I'm kind of hiding it no
spoilers that sort of thing so we have
the HTML the CSS and the JavaScript
indicated by the three arrows and so
what we're gonna basically do is copy
this into github pages and so let's go
through that so we're gonna create a new
repository this time it's kind of called
Nayan and then we also have to
initialize a repository with readme that
way we can add files right away and so
the first files do mange is let's just
go ahead and type that in the top copy
and paste the JavaScript from the code
pin next one is main dot CSS this is for
the CSS now and we're just gonna go
ahead and copy and paste that in alright
this one's important we got to do the
index.html so I did some more
boilerplate here and so code pin is nice
and it does a lot of this for you
already
you know when we switch it to github
pages we're gonna have to take some
steps to go ahead and make sure that it
can find all the files and so very
simply
you know say the language is English
Google was like okay you're English now
then we have utf-8 and utf-16 and those
are the files that we just created all
right and the result is oh okay so we
get a 4-1 for 404 file not found error
and that means we have to do a little
bit more setup so if you hit click over
to settings and then you scroll down so
sorry go back a little bit so this is
the settings on the repository so you
click on that settings and you go down
to github pages and it says you know
where's the source at by default it's
none and so github pages is disabled by
default on anything except for pages
that start with you know basically your
user name github not i/o so if it's
anything else like in this case nayoung
you go ahead and have to go through the
settings and choose master branch all
right and then after we save that one
minute 37 seconds later we have a it
shows after you refreshed hit f5 it'll
show you the option where you know it
you know your your site is published
that's awesome so if we click on to that
just to show you the URL there is my
github username which is show me dot
dash D H dot pages show me get out pages
that github dot io and then when we
click on that we have the nyan cat
follows mouse that's a little bit of
credit I put at the top of the HTML and
but not a cat's not moving something's
wrong here
even Simon Cal here is just absolutely
bored about this you know it wasn't
exciting at all and so I think something
thought something is amiss and we go
back to the code pin we go to settings
and there it is
jQuery mange yes everything is jQuery
yet
so if we go and copy this will paste it
up here in the address bar we get a you
know a bunch of you know compile
minified very hard to read javascript so
we do a control a copy everything
control C and then create a jQuery
Minjae s file go and paste that in there
it looks a little different because
there's no word wrap and github pages
alright so we go back and so you save
this and then we need to go back and
edit the index file so we go we go back
we click on index.html and then right
here we have a little pencil looking
icon that you click on and that allow us
to go back and edit so here we had the
main jjs that we did before and we want
to go ahead and put this at the top of
that so this is jQuery Minjae s paste
that in there a few moments later we
have an adorable demonstration so let me
click on this hopefully this will work
and now an eye on cat follows the mouse
just like planned and that is amazing
simon cowell be very happy about that so
let me hole I have to close out this
really quick report consumes all my
memory all right go back
okay so I wanted to go over a react
demonstration and so we got some happy
Tomatoes up here I think if you're in
the know you know this is going to be a
Pomodoro timer example and so this
demonstration is to show you you know
you may be literally reacts and you want
to get that react app on the web and you
don't want to have to pay for that
so this is kind of a demonstration on
how to get that done I did not write
this timer because you know I work and
stuff I kid but uh someone put a lot of
time into this this is forked from
Alfonzo Paso fir I'm gonna guess that's
how the name is pronounced and in his
original repository is react Pomodoro
and see if I can bump this up a little
bit more alright so I fork that forking
and github just basically means stealing
someone else's code and it's allowed
everyone loves it alright and so here we
have the code here what you notice
though is there's not an index.html
anywhere so how is this even working how
we're going to be able to display this
and that's the it mentioned it in the
video and that's the github gh-pages
github pages branch and so we can click
on the branches here click here and we
notice that there's a github pages click
on that and that's very different this
is the same repository different branch
and it's a different world and so this
has the index dot HTML you know it has
all the CSS right here the images
JavaScript even some music which is
awesome and so this basically allows
github pages to actually render the
website for you and so if we go ahead
and do the demonstration of it so to
quickly talk about how that works so
you're working on your react app on the
command line this is the nerdy and
earlier side of things and you know you
serve it up you view it you love it so
what you do in that repository is you go
ahead and build it and you could build
it anywhere but you might have to move
the files but if you can choose a place
to build a build it in the root
directory of the repository and then
you're going to have a bunch of files
that will show up on
get long or get get status so go ahead
and create a new branch called github
pages gh - pages switch to that and then
that you know that repository
should be empty don't create it for a
master just create a new branch and then
go and add those files to the root
directory of the repository commit those
files push those files and hopefully
write a script to do all that for you so
only have to do it once and that's how
you kind of create a github pages branch
in one way one way to do it and so if we
show you that so here is this is you
know this is live from my github pages
website here let me see it's hard to see
but that says show show me github pages
github that IO which is you know my
username for this demonstration slash
react Pomodoro and so this is cool if
you don't know about Pomodoro it's a
great way to stay concentrated
throughout the workday and so you have
25 minute intervals once that runs out
you go and take a break that's the
social click that you have five minutes
once that bet goes back to a Pomodoro
you do that for time you get for pulling
my doors under your bill I think it's
four and then you go ahead and do a
coffee break which is 15 you do that
throughout the day and you have free
time but you also have 25 minutes of
concentration and you can click down
here it's a link that they included and
it goes to the Wikipedia or Wikimedia
yeah Wikipedia article for Pomodoro
Technique so great thing to check out I
love Pomodoro retire timers because it's
a great project to start off with and
this one was done very well it also has
if I go back see here it also has you
know the option it's very where am I
going
Maduro so go back to the readme here and
so you can also create an icon on your
phone and that's the beauty of react and
modern JavaScript frameworks once you
start learning that it's good stuff and
you know Pomodoro timer or any kind of
timer like that is a great way to start
and they also help you get organized
all right oh no oh no
there it is okay so we need to talk
about Jekyll just a little bit Jekyll is
a kind of out of the scope of
introduction to get hubpages Jekyll is
amazing and so if you go to you know
Jekyll are be calm
there's tons of documentation is great
documentation it's a little technical
it requires Ruby on your computer and so
you just follow the install instructions
for Jekyll and you can get up and
running with that the and what Jekyll is
is a static site generator and that
allows you to do very complex things and
compile it to three files you have your
index.html you have your job your
JavaScript file any of your CSS file and
that allows you to do pretty amazing
things and so you can create blogs with
that you can create very very dynamic
looking websites but essentially it's a
static site and that has an advantage of
being extremely fast and so as opposed
to a server-side rendered page static
sites will load up quickly no matter
where it's hosted at it's very very cool
stuff Jekyll is built into github I
think the co-founder of github created
Jekyll as well and so there's a little
preference on that side there's other
static site generators but I wanted to
show you this page the second link down
here is a really long link you know it's
helped at github.com articles using
Jekyll as the static site generator with
github pages they could have made that a
little shorter I think but if you click
on that you get a github page with
amazing documentation that goes over all
of this and see you ain't bump this up
again okay
and yeah so here's the overview about
github pages in Jekyll about Jekyll
themes on github and so the themes are
amazing I'm going to tell you so the
relatively responsive and means you can
use them on a mobile device and they're
great for blogs they're great for sites
they're great for demonstrating your
code you know or your project you know
or your garden if you're you know
blogging about your garden anything like
that yeah and so it goes over
adding themes yeah customizing CSS and
HTML and so setting up your github pages
site locally with Jekyll it goes over
all of it and it's all tuned for use
with github pages so close out of that
all right and so you can't talk about
Jekyll without talking about so here's
the Jekyll site by the way so it shows
you simple static blog aware and it
gives you a little command line example
of how to get started with it it can be
that easy if you're on a Mac you know or
if you're on Ubuntu or another Linux
distribution or you're really tech savvy
in Windows I got Jekyll working on
Windows and it seems to work fine I use
Windows subsystem for Linux I haven't
tried any other methods but Jekyll is
great I've used it a lot
and I use it almost primarily because
github is just so well integrated with
it so what that basically means is that
you don't need to do anything on the
command line you can use Jekyll without
ever installing it if you know what to
do it's kind of a catch-22 so if you put
the right files in the right places
places on github then it will go ahead
and compile the site for you using
Jekyll and keep it up-to-date it's an
amazing system and so you can even have
new blog articles I'd like to do maybe
another end up talk just about that but
it's very in-depth but it's kind of
difficult you kind of have to learn
Jekyll before you can use it on github
pages without having it even installed
so that brings up Hugo so Hugo is my
favorite static site generator this
thing is fast I mean fast and so they
give examples a lot of propaganda and we
can call everything propaganda so it
just describes on their side how you can
have thousands of blog articles I barely
I think I have one blog blog article
I've ever written but I like the fact
that if you have thousands of blog
articles it can go ahead and compile
that all to a HTML CSS and JavaScript
within seconds usually less than a
second and so this is written on go go
the the go language go programming
language and go is it's much like C and
it is fast and so it's compiled as well
and so go go
and Hugo can be used almost on any
platform and you really don't even have
to go through a lot of the difficulty of
and of going through some installation
procedures with other things like Jekyll
you just install it's just the exe on
Windows or you know it's a binary in
Linux in Omak and a lot of package
managers already have Hugo ready to go
and it's very similar to Jekyll has a
lot of niceties you know they're very
complementary to one another Hugo was
inspired by Jekyll so Jekyll is the
Original Gangster and it's you know
arguably still the best in that regard
but Hugo is has a lot of features that
make it appealing and they even have a
site so go Hugo dot IO right here is the
as a site to go to to learn more about
Hugo in general and then you have a link
here go Hugo dot IO hosting and the
deployment hosting on github so there's
a site dedicated to just using go here
to go with github pages and so that's
really cool and that is also a use case
and this is one of those cases where you
might have you your your markdown files
you know what you might call your source
files in the repository and then you
would compile it to the github pages
branch just like I talked before about
react that's one way to do it to keep
the code clean that way when people look
at your repository that are not just
confused as far as what's going on all
right
and so here's the go Hugo website
self-proclaimed the world's fastest
framework for building websites and I'm
not gonna argue that how we do it on
time good
so I wanted to push the limits of you
know seeing what's you know github pages
can do and so I found this it's playing
Wolfenstein 3d in the browser to go a
little do it a little story back in
middle school is in a typing class I
didn't want to be there I can type
really fast now and that's thanks to
getting done with the lessons I got a
play Wolfenstein 3d and you know you
gotta understand you know I was I was
young you know probably thirteen if that
maybe twelve and that's one heck of a
reward you know get done with your
typing lessons get more time on
Wolfenstein 3d so we're playing these on
old Mackintosh's you know color monitors
were just a brand new thing and this
this game was the game back in that day
and so click on this and I do believe
this is uh was originally created by
either Bethesda or it for an anniversary
for Wolfenstein 3d I don't know too much
about it the the readme files a little
cryptic I work this again and so this
one this time is from Jacob site Alan
and and so this code works and it's a
lot to push through a web server well
essentially your browser's doing all the
work the web server just has to give you
the files so it's not it's not that big
a deal in that regard but it's pretty
amazing what you can do in a browser and
I really just wanted to see if it work
so just go through see if this will work
live oh my god it worked
I was having issues in Firefox so Chrome
is the way to go with Wolfenstein 3d in
the browser sorry Firefox so you go new
game I don't know how loud this is gonna
be and we gotta go I'm death incarnate
was good we're going to the max
difficulty go level one just to show you
works just fine
oh there's baddies I gotta go I gotta go
I'm a pacifist
I just got to get to the secret spoiler
there's a secret here oh that got me I'm
pretty awful I don't want to spend too
much playing time playing that all right
so that's Wolfenstein 3d the browser you
can see up here
well maybe can't see but it's show me
github pages github that I Oh slash
wolf3d and and basically I just I forked
that repository and it just worked and
so this this is another page that uses
github pages branch and I think just a
little bit of cleanup is done I don't
know if anything's changed actually yeah
see it's so full 3d to index dot HTML
that's about all the changes that were
made and that's that and so I think that
went a little bit under time we're still
doing good on time it's anyone had any
questions anybody oh we got a question
here limitations so I think you maybe
saw a little bit of it when I was doing
the the nyan cat example where basically
if you try to reach out to a CD in a
content delivery network it won't want
to pull those those in basically the web
server only wants to link to websites
within that repository or assets within
that repository and so as you saw what I
did I kind of pasted that into the
browser copy and paste that into its and
you own file the repository and that got
it up working again you could put that
in if you do if you're using node you
can probably put that as a part of the
build procedure to go and grab those get
the freshest and latest if you want to
do that and a part of you know you know
NPM in general is that you know whenever
you build it it's going to do that
anyways I think I think you know you
have to update but I think that's the
biggest limitation
I haven't seen any limitation as far as
Java syrup goes I haven't dug deep into
it I don't think because you know get up
pages just giving you giving the user
the files it's like here's a JavaScript
file an index file in a CSS file and as
long as those aren't referencing
external sites you get that in and then
JavaScript you just just run on the
user's computer as is and so you know as
far as grabbing assets through
JavaScript I think that might be
possible linking to another server that
might be possible but if you're linking
to another server
you know why are using github pages in
the first place or it could be an API so
you get to do a Twitter API through
JavaScript possibility possibly there's
no way get help can prevent that in
essence there are some limitations as
far as Jekyll themes go basically what
out like so if you wanted to go the
route of using the web interface no
command line at all and you wanted to do
a Jekyll and a blog through github pages
you basically be limited to a certain
amount of themes I do believe there's
ways to overwrite the themes make them
better improve on them but if you just
want to use it as is there are only a
certain amount of themes that github
themselves support and in addition to
that if you were to do custom theme
there's only certain amount of plugins
that github will do automatically for
you without you having to go to the
command line to do it automatically and
so I think that's done to protect
themselves because that codes being run
on their site and so that they're really
kind of protective about what Jekyll is
doing on their servers and so you have
the the Jekyll official official plugins
only and besides that I don't think
there are any other limitations that I
know of do you think of anything in
specifically no can that answer your
question any anything else you guys down
here no yeah
I don't know I don't think you can use
PHP because B the question was can use
PHP and I don't believe so the PHP would
have to be run on github servers and I
don't think github would like to take
that liability because that phq just go
do anything it wants
in essence basically the Jekyll Ruby is
kind of acting as the PHP but only when
there's a change so only when you update
your repository does the Jekyll kick in
and and and start looking for those
changes and adding files so no PHP yes
yes yeah I got some nods from some
JavaScript aficionados
it's it'll be in the JavaScript code
right guys so you can I there may be
ways to salt that that's beyond knowing
that we're getting nods now we're
getting nods now yeah I think it's a
very complicated subject I think I think
tokens and keys are best left to the
server side and at that point it might
be worth looking into getting a virtual
private server to host your stuff on
which is a whole another whole nother
talk so I'd say the quick answer with
this based on like the how many these I
got I would say no I would not put the
tokens in the JavaScript you could
wouldn't wouldn't want to do it though
oh I didn't know that okay yeah so just
repeat that a gig is kind of the limit
to the repository so I was thinking
about hosting all my roms on there I'm
not gonna do that now not gonna do it
and what you say the bandwidth limit was
one 100 gigs a month that's a lot that's
a lot and so if you keep your site
simple if you're even video I think
you'd be fine unless you just blow up
and you're you know you know news
channel 9 links to your your your github
pages I think you'll be fine but in
general if you're especially if you're
just doing a blog images and texts are
pretty cheap all right
did that satiate all your your early
yearnings about github pages I think so
I think so all right we're good we're
offline
[Applause]